Welcome back to Phoenix and Flame.
And if you are a first-time visitor here,
I'm so glad to have you. This is going to
be another amazing Phoenix
and Flame podcast. We have an incredible
guest with us.
Her name is Nicola Robbins. Now,
Nicola helps organizations and leaders
navigate transitions that seem
to have their own minds.
Her work sits at the intersection of
sustainability,
complexity science, and indigenous
knowledge systems.
She draws on 30 years of work across
Africa and 25 years
in the Ngoma tradition of Southern Africa.
Nicola, welcome to Phoenix and Flame.
Thanks so much, Dana. Good to be here.
Now that sounds very impressive,
and it is. And also, I want to add in your
book.
I'm going to kind of just toss it in there
because we're going to kind
of flow back and forth. You were auditing
a diamond mine
in Australia, and you heard the mountain
speak to you.
So at some point, we're going to have some
space to
you know, to create space to talk about
that.
I want to toss that out because ~ my gosh,
this is you're this amazing person with
science in the background.
You've got your master's in industrial
ecology from Yale.
And then you also have this wonderful
journey that you took where
you heard the mountain speak to you.
So I love the eclectic place. So tell must
just start wherever you would like,
wherever's comfortable for you,
whether it was
back in the beginning or on the mountain
and we're just gonna kinda flow back
and forth and get this whole story out.
Okay, I will start on the mountain,
seeing we're already here. And I had
graduated from Yale about five years
beforehand. And people like me,
I was young, I was I was sort of in my
early 30s,
and I had a degree that was quite sought
after in some ways from business because
the whole field of environmental science
and sustainability was just coming into
expression. This was the late 1990s,
1999, to be precise.
And so I got an opportunity, even though
I'm based in South Africa,
I got an opportunity to fly to lots of
parts of the world to do consulting,
probably at a much too young age,
because I honestly probably didn't know
enough about organizations.
I just knew about sustainability,
thanks to Yale and some studies at the
University of Cape Town.
So off I went, and it was a it's a long
flight from Cape Town to Australia.
You fly to Perth, and that's itself,
you know, about a day. And then you you
fly north four hours.
In a smaller aeroplane, a sort of
mid-sized jet,
and you descend into the mine.
The mine is called Argyle Diamonds.
It's in what's known as the Kimberley
Mountain Range of Northwestern Australia.
Now, I'm a very straight scientist.
I don't have imaginary friends.
I you know, I I I just I'm I you know what
I mean.
I'm I'm not that kind of
Dude.
I'm sort of yeah, very down the line,
very scientific. And
I've got my little audit pad and I'm doing
an environmental audit
of Argyle Diamonds. And it's exquisitely
beautiful,
right? It is so remote, there's nothing
for miles in terms of big cities.
But there is obviously a local community ~
who live in the vicinity.
And what I didn't know at the time,
and I should have known if I'd been a
better consultant,
was that Argyll Diamonds is actually a
sacred site.
I had no idea. It wasn't in the it wasn't
in the news at that time because this
was like what nearly 30 years ago.
So it it just it wasn't a big issue.
And ~ totally by surprise,
I thought, you know, maybe I'm a little
bit stressed after a long maybe I've
got jet lag, but I'm walking along with
one of the mine managers.
And he's talking about what's called
business process reengineering,
when you literally you start taking all of
your ex imp your implicit knowledge,
all the knowledge people have.
And you start writing it into documents,
and then it goes into a computer.
So you can see this whole transition that
was even taking place
in the mining industry to make things much
more almost computerized,
more organized, right?
Right. Mm-hmm.
And suddenly I'm walking along and he's
talking about this,
and I hear this other voice. And it it it
says to me,
This land is sacred. Nothing can justify
what's being done to the earth.
Now that was so impossible for me to hear
as a scientist with
a very straight mind that I literally
forgot it.
Instantly. It went straight out of my
mind.
And so it would have been fine,
right? Because then that's fine.
But the problem was it seemed as if my
body or something else didn't forget.
Because from that moment on I started to
have kind of strange symptoms,
shaking, panic attacks.
anxiety increasingly heading off the
charts and weird stuff as well.
So I spent the next two two weeks kind of
finishing up the audit.
I sort of remember being on autopilot and
then thankfully escaped back home
to Cape Town because whatever had happened
had not gone down well with me.
And let me just toss in and say I love
your description so far because
I'm thinking of myself and other people
who have experienced something that
we don't understand. We don't have a a
space in our the way the the
the construct of how we view the world,
there's not a space for it in our mental
construct.
And so we just we just flush it because we
don't there's no space
in our mental construct. We don't know
what to do with it.
And so we just we we try to flush it and
we might flush it mentally,
but what you're what I hear you saying is
our body is functioning on
a whole other level. And from from someone
who works with people with trauma,
I totally
Yes.
understand that.
Yes, that may that's a beautiful way to
describe what I experienced at the time.
And it was confusing because I didn't know
anything had happened.
And yet my body obviously knew.
Your body did. Mm-hmm.
Have you run across Bessel Vanderkolk's
book,
The Body Keeps the Score?
Yeah, so as I was writing the book,
and I obviously I thought about it,
you know, I I went into a bit of a healing
journey in order to
fix the anxiety primarily. ~ and so I did
get to read quite a lot about
~ embodied things, embodied cognition,
~ the body keeps the score. It was very
much a classic.
Yes, so absolutely. ~ and also Peter
Levine's book,
~ I know what it's called, but it's it's I
know Peter Levine does a form
of therapy where you literally shake.
you literally shake off this kind of
frozen energy that isn't
Mm-hmm.
able to move through the body and then
keeps us kind of stuck in
an almost trauma response. So yeah,
it it could have all been linked to that.
Well, Nicola, let me ask you another
question.
And I know we have a lot more to get to,
but already I'm full of questions.
Because I I I I've seen people walk
through ~ interesting journeys.
And I'm wondering how you were able to
create space for what really happened
and honor it in light of, I'm imagining,
maybe your own mind and other people if
you were to venture out.
Because sometimes I feel like when we
experience something strange that
we don't understand.
One of our natural inclinations at times
is to reach out and tell someone else.
And if we tell, I'm gonna say the wrong
people,
typically I don't like to say words like
right or wrong,
but let's say unsafe, right? If we tell
someone who is unsafe,
then frequently we get invalidated.
They'll tell us, you're you're crazy,
it's just this, it's just that.
And they minimize, they marginalize,
they invalidate until we are questioning.
ourself and we don't end up creating space
for the actual event,
what actually happened, because we're too
busy pushing it aside
and listening to other people who are
they're also minimizing it because they
don't
underst to their credit, they don't
understand it either.
And they're trying to find an e an
explanation to help us
be comfortable with what happened when
we're not supposed to
be comfortable with what happened.
We're supposed to receive it.
Yeah. So I didn't know all of this,
what you've just said, right? Because I've
just studied something else.
I don't know anything about psychology,
I've never studied that. I grew up in
South Africa and this was I I was born
in the late sixties, in the middle of the
most intensive period
of apartheid repression. I'm growing up in
a low level war
and my body knows as well.
My mind does not, because I'm growing up
in what's called white South Africa,
this kind of suburban ideal that's
separated off from
the the horror of what's actually going on
in this country.
And in some ways, this mirrors my
experience.
My mo my body knows what's going on,
but my mind is not, my you know,
my my kind of conscious mind. And so I had
very much what you
what you said there, Dana, which is this
idea that there are people I can't talk
to about this because in white South
Africa you don't talk about it.
Right? But the body always knows that
there is there is disruption,
there is dis dislocation, there is
something going on.
And I was nine years old. I think the
trauma was widespread.
You didn't have to be be you know,
to be black
And actively repressed to experience the
trauma of South African war.
But I suddenly woke up in that sense.
At the age of nine, I I actually there was
a the young,
young kids, the young pupils from the
school were demonstrating at
the bottom of where my school was located,
and in they were they were demanding to be
taught in their mother tongue instead
of Afrikaans, which was the language of
the oppressor.
And I went and I saw eye to eye,
one of these, it was a young boy,
same age as me, nine years old.
And so that was an awakening, right?
And I suddenly realized that there were
things that I couldn't have said.
There were things I didn't say say,
because I knew all along. And so that
low-level trauma was there.
I didn't get it from the mountain.
There was a a mirror effect almost.
And so when I got home,
This had been really sort of baked in,
and I didn't talk to anyone. I just knew I
was stressed.
And so I tried to manage the stress for a
while.
I went to a few massages. It's probably a
bad idea in some ways because they weren't
relaxing massages. They were very deep
tissue.
And what they did was they amplified the
symptoms.
And within, which is called rolfing,
by the way, it's like super, super deep ~
facial work.
And
w it it definitely amplified everything.
And I from that point on it got worse and
worse and worse.
I suddenly began to see things,
hallucinations if you if if you like,
but I'm also a scientist. And so I'm
saying,
well those might be hallucinations,
but they're interesting. Because there's
there there seem to be messages here.
I'm I'm hearing things from them.
Yeah, it got wetter and weather and I
don't have to go into that.
But I I I can say it it took me quite a
long time
more than six months to eventually say,
I I better go to psychotherapy.
This was quite a thing for me.
This is quite a leap, because
psychotherapy was never on my list of
things.
But on my bucket list, you know.
So it always felt
It's not on many people's bucket list.
a little bit special. And here I was a
white South African and I was like,
go to psychotherapy. Like that's just high
paid,
you know, individualistic, blah blah.
And so I was quite critical. Nonetheless,
off I trotted. And ~
That was useful, you know. And and I guess
I did get to to talk to her.
But I did work out quite early on in my
relationship with her that when
I told her about the weird stuff,
the psychotherapist did get quite worried,
you know. and so I did and this is not a
good thing,
right, in terms of transparency,
but I did really start to filter what I
was telling her because I realized
I kind of really needed this relationship.
But at the same time I didn't want her to
freak out totally because
it felt like that would take me into an
unsafe space where she would think
I was too weird. You know. And so I had a
bit of a is that a mature relationship.
Maybe start referring you for an R.
I of your head, thinking you had a brain
tumor or something.
No, but
no. I mean I just I thought she might
think I was mad,
you know, and like, you know, anyway,
yeah. It was a bit mad.
that's you bring up an interesting point
though because when we're experiencing
something and some people will and some
people won't.
I mean I've had lots of guests on my
podcast and some of them have pointed
out that some of us and I think you
probably will agree that some people
are more open to experiences for different
reasons.
and you will on the surface, this is why I
really wanted to have you
on on the podcast because on the surface
You are a, like you said, you said a
straight thinking scientist.
You're not someone that was going to just
kind of just create something
and say this happened when really it was
something that you're just kind
of creating of your own volition.
Because there's a difference between
things that we're creating in our
own mind for different reasons,
not judging that, right? Different
reasons,
versus something external that's that the
source was not us.
The source was external.
When you have someone who who has had the
training that you have had
and the mind that you have, that mind is
not going to go into hyperbolic mode.
That mind is not going to exaggerate and
and create because naturally,
because I have to think about who's
listening to this podcast and who's
watching
and I have to speak on their behalf
because they can't make the comments,
they can't ask the questions. And so I'm
thinking there's gonna be some that
are they're thinking they yeah,
mm-hmm. Yeah, sure.
Right. Which is why I love the fact that
you were not inclined in that direction.
Some people just kind of go through life
and they're just sort of inclined
to things that are more creative and
they're more open to those experiences.
You were not. And this happened to you.
Yeah, I was not. And also, apart from the
scientist,
I grew up in war. I've got this deeply
pragmatic sense of you know,
we have got to change the government.
That's the most important thing,
right? And then rebuild an entire society
so that it is no longer racist.
And I so I've got this very, very I don't
have time for,
you know, philosophy and all of that
stuff.
~ I discount it completely.
I don't know, but at that point in my
twenties I did.
So what was it? And I know there's we
don't we could talk for hours.
I feel like we could talk for days about
everything
Right.
that you went through. And I and I totally
respect and and am honoring
of of how hard it must be for you to
condense down something that has that
is so because I like I said, I've read
parts of the book.
And guys, go read the book. You're gonna
understand what I'm when
I make these comments, you're gonna know
what I mean when you read the book.
But what is it? Cause I think about when I
read your bio.
And and also thinking about my background
and with with you know working with
corporations and businesses and being the
queen of boundaries and all these kinds
of things, I hear the two words that stuck
out to me that I really,
really wanted to hear what your
experience,
how it helped you, was sustainability and
uncertainty.
Because you were saying that you part of
what you experienced,
and feel free to share whatever of that
you would like.
the messages that you received and what
was going on inside of you,
you said you were able to take that and
move that into
how you help the businesses that you work
with to have sustainability,
to deal with uncertainty. Those are two
big words.
Uncertainty behind that is fear and
sustainability.
Anybody can work great for, I don't know,
three months, six months. And but if they
don't,
if they don't have the right thing going
on,
if they don't have
things in a row, then they're gonna gas
out.
So I'm really interested in what you
experienced,
what you took from it, and how you're
helping with sustainability and
uncertainty.
How does that work?
So that is quite ~ a sort of patchwork of
connections,
and I'll try and sketch it for you very
simply.
Because even though I really appreciated
the psychotherapeutic space, and I had two
years of twice a week psychotherapy,
and I was in a strong relationship and a
useful relationship,
even though I was filtering it a wee bit,
right? She was very clear that I was
depressed.
I was very clear that I might be
depressed,
but ~ there was something going on besides
depression because it was
it was bloody interesting. You know,
I was seeing things, I was hearing things,
I was becoming aware of things that I
could not have known.
So, sort of six months into that
therapeutic process,
I I also went to a traditional healer.
And ~ the traditional healer
In South Africa is called it's an Ngoma
practitioner or a sangoma.
And Ngoma means to dance, it means ritual,
it means drum. And this is a very embodied
practice.
It's it's only a few thousand years old.
It's not, you know, one of these fifty
thousand year old traditions.
It's relatively modern in the sense that
it coemerged with agriculture.
agropasturalism with societies in which
people were building wealth.
It wasn't small bands of hunter-gatherers
in perfect harmony,
right, with nature. It was a different
kind of society and in some respects
a little bit more like our modern society.
Not to the degree we have it, but there
was accumulation of a degree of wealth.
And the need to deal with that and to work
out if
I'm planting my crops
I'm worried about uncertainty because if I
plant them and it doesn't rain,
I'm in trouble. You know, how how am I
going to deal with the fact that
~ as I store the grains, the rats get into
the granary?
You know, this is what suddenly gives rise
to more complex societies.
And Ngoma was a knowledge system,
or is a knowledge system that emerged
around about that time and then made
its way down through Africa to arrive here
in South Africa just a
few thousand years ago.
And so I was very lucky to live in a
country where where these knowledge
systems
still exist. Not in the old way,
because they've obviously weathered 500
years of colonialism,
but they are still there and they are
still practiced.
And so some way through the
psychotherapeutic journey,
I said, okay, I've I've got to get a
second opinion.
And I went to a traditional healer,
and what she did was she threw the bones
for me.
The bones are a literally a collection of
objects and there are some bones,
animal bones in there, there are some
shells,
there's a coin, there's a dice,
I I mean it's just a you know,
it's it's a whole mixture of things.
There are about thirty little bones,
and the trad traditional healer can hold
them in her hand,
and then she'll say to me, Blow on the
bones,
yeah? And then she will throw them down on
the floor.
And there's a mat there. And the bones,
of course, make this random or whatever,
but a pattern.
appears. It's it's really beautiful.
It's it's beautiful. And then of course we
all like to look at
the pattern because we're fascinated by
what the bones are saying.
And as I leant forward to look at this
sort of jumble of bones,
I instantly remembered exactly what had
happened in the mountain.
A had no
Called for that. I hadn't even told my
therapist because I hadn't remembered.
So I saw this pattern. I don't know how
this happened.
It's really weird. But I suddenly
remembered and I s and I remembered.
And I said to her, ~ you you I call her
Gogo because she's like you
you call her grandmother, you know,
Gogo. I said, Gogo, grandmother.
~ I just remembered something that
happened.
And I said the the mountain spoke to me.
And she's like, ~ yeah, yeah, yeah,
you know, there's like this has the
mountains that can speak to you.
And yeah, you know, it's totally
comfortable that this
is totally fine, you know. She's not
saying
I love that.
Yeah, so I had this but very clear recall.
~ not just fuzzy, clear, clear,
clear. I saw exactly, I saw exactly.
~ and so so it was, you know, she actually
recommended me to someone and
I ended up training in that tradition.
And I'm doing a bit of a long story,
but the reason I'm doing that is because
this is the link to uncertainty.
Is she doesn't know how those bones are
gonna fall.
There is no map.
Except the one that emerges in front of
her.
And we make sense of it together.
You know, she will lean forward and she'll
point out this bone means that,
this bone means that this is your mother,
this is, you know, this could be a
mountain,
this is your ancestor, you know,
this is money. And we're starting to look
at the relationships between
all of these objects that are now
representing,
but in a very fluid and dynamic way,
my reality. This was an amazing way of
working.
Because instead of this absolute certainty
that I had depression,
and therefore the next step, and this is
what I resisted,
was to go onto antidepressants.
And I don't have a problem with
antidepressants,
but I just genuinely, you know,
I you know, I it didn't feel right.
And
Yeah.
it felt like things were dangerous for me.
I I could I didn't feel good about making
a mistake.
That felt dangerous. And so this fluid
reality where she learned forward
and said, Listen, man, I I
didn't say that. She said, she said,
listen, Google, because she called me ~
grandmother as well.
It's a very sign of respect to a client.
I don't, I, I don't know for sure we can
help you,
but I can tell you that this is a this is
a sickness that in many cases
has been cured. And you know,
it and and and this sickness we know very
well.
And this sickness is
That in many cases it what?
In many cases, what did you say?
It is good. It is good. We know how to
cure the sickness that
Okay, okay.
you have. Yeah. And the sickness is a it's
it's ~ it's also called affliction with
spirits. It's called the sickness that
confounds the doctors because
it its symptoms are multi they can be in
different ways.
The sickness can express in your legs.
You can go lame, you can be blind,
you can have psychological, mental
illness,
you can have so many different expressions
of the sickness,
but they know underneath behind it.
That is a spiritual affliction.
It is expressing through the body in a
different way.
And
So you're you're saying
it was a spiritual sickness that started
with the mountain with your experience
with
the
That sickness is a spiritual sickness that
was catalyzed.
It was woken up, not catalyzed,
it was woken up by the mountain.
An experience of cognitive dissonance,
right? That couldn't, couldn't,
I couldn't read. It was woken up.
Something shocked me. ~ but the sickness
itself is not an individual sickness,
it's a sickness of society. And for some
reason,
certain people.
Who are maybe sensitive, yeah,
even though they didn't know they were
sensitive,
they can have an experience that results
in that sickness expressing through their
body in individual symptoms. So the again,
and I I'm sort of
in a very indirect way talking about
certainty and uncertainty.
~ and we can get to sustainability later.
But essentially what we're saying here is
this is about a way of working where there
isn't direct one to one correlations,
not causal, you know. It is
There is so many possible pathways whereby
this social sickness could come
to express through me. She doesn't need to
nail it down.
She doesn't need to say it was because of
the mountain,
or because you're a white South African,
or because of apartheid, or or all.
She just knows I recognize, I recognize
that sickness from the patterns,
from how you're talking, from the feeling
I get when you're next to me,
from how the bones have fallen.
Yeah.
Nice.
They do know how to fix it.
So so what okay,
speaking from from someone who ~ doesn't
have that background and trying
to kind of come alongside and really
understand,
so if she doesn't if she doesn't look at
it from a point of causality,
which I I believe I'm hearing you say
that,
then how does she determine what needs to
be done to help you with the sickness?
Because I think in more Western type
medicine
They they have to identify the etiology.
They have to, what's the cause?
And once they have that, then they know,
okay, this is the cause of this.
Then now we know we do this because this
is the cause.
So if you're looking at it from a
different space and you're looking at
it from a different mentality where a
cause isn't necessarily important,
how how did she know how to help you with
what she has termed a sickness?
That is a great question. So it is not
that cause is not important.
It is that we cannot draw a line between
cause and effect in a linear way.
It's not a straight line. It's a nonlinear
thing.
So it is, we could say it's messy.
She knows that what is expressing through
me is.
Has things that happened before that that
fed into it.
And we can talk about apartheid,
we can talk about growing up in a liberal
household and where people don't really
often speak directly to each other.
We can talk about mountains and all those
sorts of things.
But we cannot nail it down. We cannot say,
you know, you had this experience and
therefore.
So they also know that in in in Ngoma
culture,
most illnesses.
Or many, many illnesses, including some
physical illnesses,
are not seen simply as individual.
So again, you've got this understanding
that illness comes from the society.
And when society is sick, when society is
not well,
and again, this is South Africa,
right? And this is sort of late-stage
industrial capitalism,
and this is extraction, accumulation,
you know, extraordinary racism.
When society is sick, people
get this particular sickness more and
more,
this affliction by spirits. And what they
know is that when
we try to solve this or when we try to
cure the sickness using sort
of normal, simple herbs, yeah,
you know, okay, you've you've you you seem
to have ~ a sore throat.
Let me give you the herbs for sore throat.
They don't work. They don't work.
Because what will happen is the sore
throat will go away and it ends
up being a headache or it ends up being a
vision issue.
This is strange. Yeah, it
Just moves around, migrates.
moves around, it it shape shifts,
it takes expression. This is one of the
the signals that this is this kind
of sickness. So the the sickness is solved
by ~ or solved,
maybe solved, but it's it's it's it's
treated through a ritual.
A ritual training, in fact. It's not only
a cure,
it's also a training.
It's a, in my case, four-month 24-7
intensive ritual that takes place
in a liminal space just outside of the
city,
in between the city and the bush,
or in between the village and the bush,
right? ~ and it's a very intensive ritual
where you are in
a process of in many respects,
you go back to your childhood.
Very, very deeply. It's a regression to
some extent,
if I put it into kind of more Western
terms.
~ and your teacher is your father.
And he or she, doesn't the gender doesn't
matter,
he or she will say to you, I am now your
father,
and you are my child. And you in those
four months get an opportunity
to grow up again. And in that process,
everything is carefully given their place.
Everything is put into place and that they
know the place for everything.
And this is I'm talking about
relationships,
who comes first, where your spirits are,
how everything needs to be nicely placed
or rightly placed for society to be well.
This has got to do with boundaries,
by the way, because boundaries aren't
declared.
They like when everything's in its place,
boundaries emerge. They they they just
happen.
They are they just are there. And so I
Mm-hmm.
went through that that ritual,
and in that process, something in my mind
said.
You know, this is a different way of of
healing.
And then I said this is a different way ~
of approaching the need
for a complex transition in a society,
a society where industry is out of
control,
is chaotic, is, you know, resulting in
these bizarre realities that we seem to
live.
How can we how can we make the translation
between how people are
healed in a four-month ritual and it would
mean remarkably effective tough
but remarkably effective how do we do
something similar in in industry
and I couldn't work it out for 20 years
wow.
sorry to say but I did eventually
So you eventually
well, you know, some things take time.
But I love the way you're representing
Okay.
this because sometimes people are and I
hear this,
people have different political stances
and political feelings.
And in the United States it's kind of an
interesting landscape.
And
Well.
and ~ you know, you run into people that
are very feel very ~ out of control.
and very upset. And what I'm hearing you
say is that it might be something
systemic,
it might be something cultural that's
going on,
but there is a way to ha to have some
agency,
to not feel like you've bit just been
sucked down a hole of sickness
and you you can you have a place because
things that
are systemic heal
one person at a time. Because a system is
full of individuals.
And so it's kind of like it's working
together,
but also if an individual doesn't feel
like they have any agency,
if they're just so upset and so full of
the sickness of what's going on around
them,
then they just sit in the sickness and
they don't they don't feel like they have
the capacity to move forward. And they're
so upset by what's going on around them,
what they're witnessing. ~
I that's one of the things that I'm
hearing you say is that a person
can feel that and there's also a to heal,
to have that agency.
And it's it it is the person who has the
sickness worst.
Like I mean, I had a bad sickness,
so bad that ~ you know,
I I couldn't be in a normal functioning ~
role in society.
I mean I went into business and I was
hearing and seeing things that
That were just not useful, right?
In terms of business. I would hear too
many voices at the
What?
same time in the boardroom, it does not
help.
So I'm I'm losing my functionality.
I have this sickness badly. The assumption
is I'm not the only one with it.
I'm the one with the most overt ~
expression of it.
I've got the symptoms that are really,
really high. So my job is to go off and do
this cure,
this healing, and this training.
So the training.
Component of this four-month ritual is how
to divine,
how to throw the bones, like that old Gogo
that I went to,
right? I learn how to do what she's doing.
The idea of this is that we can't afford
to heal one individual at a time.
We're going to do intensive healings for
some individuals because they're
dysfunctional in society. But that
intensive healing is going to give them a
skill.
And they're gonna come back to society and
they're going to be able
to work with with anyone. With anyone who
else ~ has problems that seem
to go back to uncertainty and y y you
know,
problems that really can't seem to find a
way forward,
systemic problems, as you put it.
A feeling of craziness, although there's
no one point.
But I mean, I've just, you know,
I've woken up in in America that's not the
one I thought it was,
for example.
And so is this about me or isn't it?
Well, that's the kind of problem one might
go to a Ngoma practitioner for.
Were you in you know, a traditional
society in in Southern Africa?
It's not a I've got a cold, let me take an
aspirin,
you know. It's it's not like that.
It's a different kind of problem.
It's a kind of a systemic problem.
In traditional culture, it's spiritual.
In traditional culture, people might say,
~
Those spirits were never seated nicely.
Things were not put in place for the
people who are making decisions
in this culture. And so the work is not to
fix the
one or two obviously dysfunctional people.
The work is to train people to work with
groups of people
so that it can spread through the society
without having to go one at a time.
Because it's too expensive, too long.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. It has to ripple through society.
So it is both individual and collectivist,
very different culture and understanding
of where the roots of deep sickness lie.
I love this. So I have a comment and then
a question,
and then we'll wrap up. So the comment is
I'm listening to you talk.
It's reminding me of a quote from Brene
Brown.
I don't know if you've ever heard of her.
She deals a lot with shame and
vulnerability.
She's done TED Talks. She's she's just
fabulous.
She's funny, self effacing. It's just
hysterical.
But she said she made a comment that
shame,
I know we're not talking about shame
exactly,
but she said shame was created.
in relationships and it has to be healed
in relationships.
And that's kind of in a way what I'm
hearing you say about
a a ~ system, that something that was
created in a system needs to be healed
in a system. Which leads me to my question
of let's pull back in that last word
of sustainability. You know, if we have
someone who's listening right
now and they're part of a team or they're
maybe a team lead and
They're concerned about their their their
business and and their people.
What is something you could share with
them from your experience that would help
them encourage sustainability with with
their team?
So sustainability as it's presently
practiced,
and some people call it sort of ~
corporate social responsibility,
it's got lots of different names,
but essentially what it's doing is it's
dealing with this large-scale transition,
which means we come into a situation where
we are now respecting planetary planetary
boundaries, we are no longer emitting
large amounts of carbon,
but also we are socially just.
So that this is a big transition that
we're in.
At the moment, this transition that we're
on.
~ is critically important because it's
existential.
If we get it wrong, we're going to be
taken out by extreme heat events,
not a hundred years from now, 10,
15 years from now or less. So we are going
to face an extraordinarily difficult
and uncertain place. So sustainability is
essentially needing
to bring organizations into a way of
working far more intelligently with these
kinds
of constraints and realities.
And one might say, having just learned how
to divine and throw the bones,
what a cool thing, right? Why don't I go
into the boardroom and throw the bones?
This would be fun, you know, and we can
all sit around and look at the bones
and you know this is this is how not to
bring indigenous knowledge back
to the boardroom because what you're doing
is effect,
you're you're ripping it out of context.
You're extracting it from how the bones
are meant to work in a context where
people
deeply understand spirits and ritual and
traditional medicines, and you're plonking
them onto a boardroom.
And that's just the same extractive old,
you know, commoditized process ~ that that
that that is the source of so much
of our problem. And this is why it took me
20 years,
because that was paradoxical. I I mean to
bring it back to
my community because that's where the
problem is,
but I can't.
Yeah.
And essentially
it took me a while to work it out that one
of the things I've ended up doing now,
and this is probably 80 or 90 percent of
the work I do now,
is I I work with teams of people and I get
them to really,
really understand the context of whatever
they're doing.
This is this is not you know rocket
science.
It's we we know that context matters.
So, what is context? Well, it's like
what's the history of this?
If we're looking at, for example,
climate change and what are the risks.
To the supply chain of my company in
respect of a changing climate.
Understand the context. What is your
business model?
Who are you doing? What is, you know,
what is going on? Where is the risk
relevant and less relevant?
And so really get people to understand,
for example, how they've been denying
climate in the last 10,
15 years. And that's relevant as well
because it's it's impacted.
So really.
frame contextually. That's the first step.
The second, and this is really linked to
the whole idea of divination,
we want to represent this problem in a way
that's quite dynamic.
So don't necessarily model everything to
used using data about y you can do this,
and of course we must do this.
And we must understand the flows of carbon
and we must understand,
you know, everything we can about carbon
and its interaction with the climate.
But also look at who's involved.
Have some kind of way of representing the
elements.
And sometimes what we do is we actually
have people representing elements
of the system. You can be the supply chain
policy and you can represent ~ you know,
the the ~
this the the executive team and you can
represent the supply chain team
and you can represent right and so you
actually or you have little stickies.
And so there are l lots of ways to do this
and there are lots of methods that
do this. But that process of dynamically
representing allows people
to speak very freely. In the same way as
when I looked forward and
I remembered what had happened at the
mountain when I saw those bones.
That's my experience of working with
teams.
They have a
Their recall of interesting stories of
things they know about their
own supply chain. Right? So their
Mm-hmm.
minds are being stimulated to remember
things and they feed the stories in.
And the last thing we do together is we we
make sense of this together.
So we discuss it. So we make sense of
things and we track.
Essentially, we are tracking what's going
on.
What are these stories? What are they
telling us?
And it it's not the most
Perfect tick-boxy, you know, you still
have to do your carbon footprint
and all of that. But what it does is it
awakens in the teams,
and any team will have this experience.
It's it's pretty reliable. they start
feeling warmer,
more heard, more respected, more part of
the solution.
And that level of respect, that level of
humanity,
particularly in an age of AI.
I think makes
Mm.
this worth doing. Even though I can't
guarantee we'll fix climate change.
I can't guarantee, you know, you'll
decrease your carbon footprint next year.
That warmth makes the possibility just a
little bit more likely.
I love that so much. So unfortunately
we're out of time and I know that
the listeners are thinking, my goodness,
I I want to know more about Nicola's
experience and and and more details.
And truly, you guys, you've got to read
this book.
It's it's it's intense. So how where do
you want them to go to to ~ connect with
you more if they'd like to know more about
what you experienced
and what you represent and your wisdom and
all of that?
So I I'm I'm just in a process of
transition myself because I've got
to that point where having published the
book,
and this was only about six months ago,
I published the book, and it it felt to me
like my my company for the last
20 years has been a pretty mainstream
sustainability consultant.
I haven't been talking about this stuff at
all.
It wouldn't have gone down well with my
clients.
And so, although I still work under that
brand,
the company's called Insight.
~ I'm starting to put together my own
little offering and my own website.
So that will be under probably my name,
Nicolarobins.com, but it's not up yet.
I have the book website though,
which is divinermind.com. So people are
welcome to go and have a look at the book.
Welcome to buy the book ~ and review the
book.
~ but yeah, I you know, you'll find my
email address on there.
You're r yeah, I'm really I'm always
fascinated.
The the the most wonderful thing about
writing a book,
Dana, has been
the chance to have conversations like this
one,
~ but also the the remarkable feedback
I've got from people who've read it.
~ and what's remarkable to me,
this took me by by surprise, is a lot of
people literally read the book
in one sitting. You know, or one or two
days.
~ they just they just I don't know,
They just pour through it. Yeah.
they go into relationships. Yeah,
they just do it. And and so they often
write back and tell me that.
So it's always been like yeah,
That's fabulous. And also i you people can
find you on
really nice.
LinkedIn as well. I found you there,
so that's that's a good place as well that
to connect.
yeah. Yeah. So that's where I'm
going. If you wanna if you wanna exchange
on any of these issues,
you wanna ask more about spirits or
healing or ~ anything,
~ more about this way I work, which is
called a t coattentional space,
by the way. That coatensional space is
this the this working with teams.
~ I will post more on LinkedIn and and on
Substack.
~ and always delighted to have
conversations.
And also not to agree with everyone,
right? So I don't use LinkedIn as an echo
chamber.
I look I use it to learn and to share.
Yeah.
That's fabulous. Well, Nicola,
thank you so much for wow, sharing such
an unique and interesting journey and
coming on Phoenix in Flame and
and giving us your wisdom and your being
transparent with us and kind
of bringing us into your space for a
while.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Dana. Your questions have been
amazing.
Thank you.
Now, guys, my goodness, I know you have
heard numerous things in this podcast that
you're thinking. I have a friend or a
relative or a coworker that absolutely
needs
to hear what Nicola Robbins has to say.
Take this podcast, copy and paste it,
send it in text, send it an email,
post it on your favorite social media
sites so we can grow our Phoenix
and Flame community. If you want to get a
hold of me more,
you can check me out on LinkedIn.
You can access me there.
I hope your day is going great.
I hope the rest of your day is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix and Flame.